there are new questions this morning
about the timeline of what unfolded on
the night of the Las Vegas massacre a
significant change has some people now
wondering whether police officers could
have stopped the gunman Steven paddock
investigators say that he shot a hotel
security guard before he opened fire on
concert goers Jamie yuccas is in Las
Vegas near the location of the shooting
Jamie good morning good morning MGM
which owns Mandalay Bay has repeatedly
turned down our request for an interview
however they did release a statement now
casting doubt over the events laid out
by law enforcement saying quote we
cannot be certain about the most recent
timeline what is currently being
expressed may not be accurate the key
question now is whether hotel security
knew there was an active shooter before
pattex deadly rampage Clark County
investigators admitted Monday hotel
security guard hey-zeus Campos was shot
six minutes before Steven paddock opened
fire on concert goers but last Friday
under sheriff Kevin mcmayhem hailed
Campos as a hero for interrupting the
shooter this was a remarkable effort by
a brave and remarkable man mcmayhem
tried to explain the changing timeline
on Nevada Public Radio but raised more
questions when he said that a
maintenance worker was also on the 32nd
floor when shots were first fired as the
maintenance man as well is arriving in
the hallway
they have some communication and they're
just riddled with hundreds of bullets
assistant sheriff Tom Roberts told the
Los Angeles Times that Campos used his
radio to call hotel security before
pattex rampage but the exact timing of
that call is still unclear mcmayhem said
that hotel security and first responders
did everything they could I don't think
the hotel dropped the bomb I can tell
you that first responder resources were
on the scene very very quickly
investigators have found that paddock
made his reservation at the Mandalay Bay
for September 25th three days earlier
than originally thought but did not
check in until the 28th they are also
trying to confirm of padic used a
freight elevator at the hotel in the
days leading up to the attack
investigators also tell CBS News that
they visited this shooting range just
outside Mesquite Nevada believing
paddock may have practiced shooting two
days before he carried out his attack in
Las Vegas Charlie